you're going to have to deregulate a
tiny number of people who are absolutely
powerhouses on generative far right tail
behavior and you're going to have to
unshackle them and then you're going to
have to somehow force a spreading of
wealth
in this deregulated system
you're going to have to recognize that
the output of different human beings
based on the kurtosis of how people are
distributed
has to be embraced so what does that
look like in real world terms Eric you
probably shouldn't be telling Elon Musk
that he's not invited to the electric
vehicle Summit at the White House Long
you know get over yourselves
um Elon and you know I've been super
critical if you want a lot of different
things isn't Next Level human being at
some level he's also a artist
he's a master showman he's a troll
he fakes things
he's a genius he's a scoundrel I mean
there's a lot going on with Elon and
what I'm trying to say is
you're going to have to start dealing
with super complicated generative people
I worked for Peter Thiel for 10 years
almost
Peter's a genius he's an out now genius
and he's a better communist than most
communist he's got the ability to run
communism in his mind
he can run capitalism and libertarianism
and anything else
you're gonna have to start stop
demonizing these people in these
completely simplistic terms you're gonna
have to invite a lot of freaks and
Weirdos according to normies
to dance and play and build and think
and you're gonna have to stop
making their lives a living hell it's
one of the things I've been thinking
about a lot we confuse
wealthy people with successful people
and we tie them all with one brush and
we say if you've got money you're evil
well
here's the really interesting news a lot
of these people tolerate people with
radically different politics Peter Thiel
and I have radically different politics
we can also finish each other's
sentences at times
you know
the world of remarkable people
needs to be more Unshackled
and more people need to be invited in
case they are also remarkable and they
come from circumstances where it wasn't
identified
you know my belief is
and I'll save this maybe towards the end
but
you need to go after your learning
disabled people
because a lot of those people are the
innovators that you desperately need
right now you're making their lives a
living hell
you're making School a daily exercise
and having your head shoved in the
toilet and a lot of those people are
super Learners that you're pretending
you're learning disabled
um
we need a new economic model that is
based on the tiny number of people who
can perform in these completely crazy
circumstances we need to make their
lives great
and we need also
to come up with a culture of service
you know which is really weird but you
don't get to keep your wealth
if all you're doing is enjoying luxury
and posting pictures on Instagram about
you know I drove my Aston Mark Martin to
get to my Bentley to get to my Gulf
Stream
if that's your lifestyle you you failed
you know the key thing is is that
serve others you have to serve you have
you just
Bob Dylan got it right you have to serve
somebody and a culture of service of
obligation
um I was just at a kind of a secret
meeting of incredible people in London
billionaires at the table in general I
said you know at some point somebody
called on me you know and
it was a peer and
said Eric has something to say I didn't
really have something to say but one of
the things I said is I just listened
to you all talking behind closed doors
about the need to help those less
fortunate
nobody would believe that that's what
you're actually talking about behind
closed doors
right and
you have to open your houses invite
people to dinner to dine with you I just
had this thing with Billy Bragg where I
ran into a festival
totally took the piss out of me in a
book and on social media
and I said why don't we share the stage
and sing a song together and he said
what are you doing on my stage I'm not
going to share this you know but when I
meet him over coffee
you know we're able to bridge things to
come together and the the issue is we
need to do some things where people you
never imagine would break bread or share
a stage
do so because this is an emergency
situation so open your homes invite
people in show people what it is that's
your actual tradition it's very hard for
an anti-semite to survive a Shabbat
dinner
and I I completely agree with you on all
that you were saying particularly when
it comes to education somebody who was a
teacher for many years I saw what we did
to the neurologically atypical I'm
neurologic atypical myself and it's
you're kidding me
how else do we unshackle potential how
else do we unleash this ball of
creativity
dark with uh
um how do I put this
look at the troll section on Reddit
it's this giant group of people telling
other people you know that thing you
believe and I saw through it a long time
ago it's like nobody can believe
anything we're in this sort of I don't
know it's like a an orgy of
not believing of nihilism
if you don't believe in anything you
lost like look it's all Bs for sure it
may be Sound and Fury signifying nothing
but if that's the answer you came up
with you just lost life
um I think what we have to do is we have
to put forward a positive Vision where
we're starting to talk about yeah you
can see when you when you come up with a
song lyric I'm in your song I'm feeling
I'm thinking it
show people what's possible show people
how to take anything
a cup of coffee you know the the story
of Robusta versus arabica beans or you
know we could take the light in this
room and the fact that I keep talking
but there's a Secret Circle at every
point in space and time otherwise we
wouldn't be able to see each other we
don't tell anybody about so they keep
talking to us about Schrodinger's cap
but they don't even understand the
beauty of Maxwell's equation the world
is just overflowing with beauty and
majesty and Transcendence and we're
caught talking about who thinks how much
of themselves and who's self-promoting
and who's who's a for clicks and
all of this stuff it's all socially
based and I think what we need to do in
part is to
do cool stuff
foreign